[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Hey, everyone.
Natalie Villalobos
here at Google I/O--
extremely proud to introduce
Jackie O-- the Jackie O--
Jackie Omotalade.
She is an environmental
justice tech maven here at I/O.
And we get to hear a
little bit about her work
and the innovations
that she's driving
in environmental justice.
Welcome, Jackie.
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE: Thank you.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So tell me, how
did you get involved
in the tech industry?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
Well, I think
that's kind of funny because
I'm kind of dating myself--
but I got involved in
tech when my uncle gave me
my first Commodore 64.
So that really does date me.
And I've been in love with
computers and technology
and all those things ever since.
So that's probably
30 plus years now.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: What was
the first project that really
struck your passion,
that knew you
wanted to get into technology?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE: I think
one of the first projects
was after I graduated
actually college.
And I was working on a
fellowship for Bill Clinton.
And I was working in Africa
on improving public health
outcomes there.
And there were so many
opportunities to use technology
in a way that was
for social good
and that would really, really
have this substantial impact
on how people experienced
their lives and their outcomes
in health and
environmental issues.
And that's when I really,
really became interested
in this cross section
between health
and environmental
justice and technology
and how all these
amazing innovations
that people are
doing and creating
could drive social good.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
So it's not just
that one industry is
siloed from another industry.
You're actually crossbreeding
this hybridization,
this place where
technology meets health
and environmental justice.
So tell me, how did you land
on environmental justice?
Why this particular topic?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE: I think
because right now, especially
in this time as we
deal with climate
change and global warming and we
see, particularly in California
with the drought, environmental
justice is the issue right now
and it affects all of us
no matter where we are.
And collectively, we really
can tackle and collect
the brain power of
all of us to address
some of these questions.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And so you settled
on Southeast San
Francisco as a place
to really dig into your work.
Tell me why that particular
community and what
you found in creating
this project.
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
Well, I think
it's so amazing that I'm
here in San Francisco, which
is the tech capital of
the world, hands down,
and I work for a fabulous
organization called the San
Francisco Parks Alliance.
It deals with parks and open
space and access to open space.
And you think of San Francisco
as being this global mecca
of wealth, technology,
prosperity, all those things,
but yet the communities in
the southeast of San Francisco
haven't been able
to access or tap
into any of those benefits
for multiple reasons.
And if you look at some of
the history of San Francisco
around some of the
environmental degradation
that happened there with nuclear
sites, with the whole landfill
and how that, seismically,
is very dangerous when
you build housing on top
of things that aren't land.
So I wanted to make sure that
communities in the Southeast
are connected to the wealth
of information and knowledge
and prosperity and
environmental justice
because the sea is rising
and lots of those people
live on the waterfront.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
So in this work, are
you making this area
more accessible, safer?
Tell me specifically how
you're addressing this problem
with this community.
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
So it's multifaceted.
I am a director of a project
called the Blue Greenway, which
is an initiative that has been
led by the San Francisco Parks
Alliance.
And what we are
doing is there is
13 miles of waterfront
shoreline in the southeast
part of San Francisco that
probably in the last 60 years
has not been accessible to
communities in the Southeast.
So you have people that
live a half a mile,
a quarter of a mile
away from the waterfront
and have not been able
to access it, touch
it, for multiple reasons.
One, some of it was
active nuclear sites.
Two, it was closed off
for industrial reasons
and other reasons.
So part of the project that I'm
leading with the Park Alliance
is around making those
areas open and accessible
to communities in the Southeast.
So it involves the cleanup.
It involves protecting the
native Bay Area species.
It involves conserving
and creating
new wetlands, which help protect
us against climate change
and sea level rising.
It involves using technology to
connect the community to what
actually is happening
on the waterfront,
because lots of
people don't know.
And I'm only one
person, and I do do
a lot of community engagement.
But at the same time,
pretty much everyone
in this day and time has a
cellphone and has a smartphone.
And part of what we're doing
is creating this platform
using mobile technology that
people can look on their cell
phone and they can
go up and down all 13
miles of that waterfront and
discover what has happened,
what will happen, and what they
can do to participate in it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
you're bringing the community
into the work.
It's not like
solving the problem,
coming in, and fixing it.
You're engaging the community
to solve for themselves
in a lot of ways.
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE: Yes.
Exactly.
It's all about
empowering the community,
because obviously I
can't do this by myself,
nor could the Parks
Alliance do it by themself.
And the community
has to value it
and has to see it as
a win-win for them.
And the way you do that is
you engage the community
and you use the fabulous
thing called technology.
Who can't sit and
twiddle on their phone
and comment on something
or drive an initiative
or suggest something?
I mean, I think that's
the beautiful thing
about technology is that
you have groupthink.
And you can have millions
of people together trying
to solve a certain problem.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
I'm very passionate about
having underrepresented groups
or communities not feel just
like they consume technology,
but they can create.
They can make the technology.
And I think a lot
of times people
just aren't in that
mindset, right?
They're just kind of
feeling like it's something
that they receive
and not something
they actively participate in.
And so we have an incredible
audience of millions
of developers around the world.
How can developers or designers
or really anyone help you?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE: Oh my god.
There's so many ways
they can help me.
First of all, they can
definitely reach out to me.
Follow me on Twitter,
@JackieOmotalade.
And I would say, comment,
give us feedback,
let us know suggestions.
Even in the two days that I've
been here-- or day and a half--
I've found out so many wonderful
things in apps and applications
that people are developing
that could be Incorporated
into this whole environmental
justice, social justice
movement that we're creating
and growing in the southeast
communities of San Francisco.
So I would love for developers
to come and donate their time
and energy to thinking big.
And every meeting I go
to and every time I'm
talking to people
in the Southeast--
like the actual
residents there-- I say,
we can think big.
We can make this
as big as we want
to make because the power
is within us to do that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
And just for those
tuning in, when
we're saying the
Southeast, we're
meaning Southeast San Francisco.
We just want to make sure
that the developers all
go to the right place.
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE: Yes.
Yes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So you've
had this extreme passion
for solving for communities and
really social justice issues
for a very long time.
With technology going in the
way of the Internet of Things
or wearables and these
new ways of technology
engaging consumers,
what do you want
to see solved in
your lifetime given
the incredible
possibilities of technology?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
I think as much
that can be solved as possible.
I would say I wouldn't even
limit it or close the door.
Whatever we can solve
in my lifetime--
and who knows what
my lifetime will be,
given what technology
is doing right now.
Maybe my body will
be in something else
in some other shape
or form or time.
But I think that one
of the big things
is making sure that underserved
communities have access
to technology, both from
a user experience but also
a participatory, actually,
creation-wise as well.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And so with your work,
are you collaborating
with other communities
around the world that might
have incurred similar issues,
or do you feel like this
particular project is
unique in what it's experienced?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE: No.
The funny thing is it's not
necessarily very unique.
It's unique in the situation
that at this time right now
in San Francisco, when you
think about San Francisco,
you don't think about
nuclear waste sites,
or you don't think
about hydrocarbon damage
and pollution done, or you
don't think of San Francisco
as having some of the
highest-- the southeast
part of San
Francisco-- as having
some of the highest asthma rates
in the state of California.
And some of those
asthma rates mirror
some of the other countries
in the developing world.
So in some ways, our
experiences are very similar.
And part of the work
I am doing is also
reaching out and
studying some of the best
practices from other
countries and what they've
done as they tackle
environmental justice
issues using technology
and other resources.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So in
the lifespan of your project,
are you at the beginning,
the middle, or the end?
And can you share a story of
maybe interacting and engaging
with the community that shines a
light on how your work is truly
improving the community in
Southeast San Francisco?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
So we're still
very much in the
beginning stages.
I mean, a lot of it is still
very much like ideation
because when you're
participatory
and when you do true
community engagement
it involves speaking out to
lots and lots of stakeholders,
which I really enjoy doing.
I love hearing people's stories.
I love when people tell me they
never thought in their lifetime
that they would
actually be able to put
their toes in the
water of San Francisco
right near their houses, which
is pretty powerful when you
think that some of
these individuals
are third and fourth generations
in those neighborhoods
and they actually never thought
that they could walk out
of their house, walk
across the street,
and actually touch the water.
So those are some of the most
powerful messages that I get.
And then also some
people thought
that-- because a
lot of the things
are former nuclear sites, it
was all classified information.
And so now the
fact that I've been
able to open that door of, OK,
this is what is happening there
and this is the timeline
for various cleanups,
et cetera and what all these
different terminologies
mean in environmental cleanup.
That is just so powerful.
I think information is
probably the best gift that you
can give people--
information connected
to how they can actually
act and change the world.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, absolutely.
I'm actually an 11th
generation Californian.
My family's been here
for a really long time.
And I live over on the East Bay.
And I feel now privileged
and completely unaware
that this was a problem
in my neighborhood.
And so do you have a website?
We're all going to
follow you on Twitter,
but is there a
central place that we
can read about this
work online and dig
into some of this research?
I know it's incredibly
powerful-- organizations
like Code for America
opening up access to-- that's
more city information.
But how do we open
up more of this
and research it and assist you?
So do you have another site?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
So there actually is.
So if you go to
sfparksalliance.org
and you search that
site Blue Greenway,
there's all the information.
And we're actually
in the process
of building a brand
new website that
will have a reservoir
of information
and pulling from data from
multiple different sources
so that anyone around
the world can find out
exactly what's going on and how
they can help and participate.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
hopefully what you set up here
is a model for what can be
then moved to other places
around the world where
they're experiencing
similar environmental
justice issues.
So we're at I/O. What has been
your favorite thing so far?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
Oh my goodness.
I'm fascinated by Project Tango.
I probably spent-- I
don't know-- maybe an hour
up there picking their
brains of everything
possible with that
piece of technology,
because in some ways, as I said,
particularly with communities
in the southeastern San
Francisco, some of them
have not been able to
experience past state,
as in before all the
environmental degradation
because it all has happened
within their lifetime, but also
future states.
A lot of people can't even
envision what is possible.
And that technology
actually makes
it happen, where
they can actually
see what a cleanup site would
look like, see what it's
like to experience their
waterfront in a different way,
but also go through
history and see
all the horrible
things that happened,
because there's lessons to be
learned from history so that we
don't repeat it.
So I think that is
just-- and visually see.
And I think visuals actually
speak to people in ways
that reading about
it just don't do.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, absolutely.
So I work on women and
technology at Google.
And prior to this
work, I was also
working with Native Americans
to help them map their lands.
A common issue with another
underserved community with them
is that sometimes they can't
find or really map correctly
the boundaries of their land.
And so when people are
encroaching on their land,
they need some GPS markers.
They need these tools
to be able to really
be in an empowered place
to defend themselves.
So after your
project is completed,
are you going to
continue working
on environmental
justice, or do you
think you'd want to move
over back into health care
or maybe take this
to another country?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
I don't know.
But I definitely see
environmental justice
connected to health because
environmental issues affect
health outcomes.
So I see that intersection.
And I also see that given
the history, particularly
with the communities
in the Southeast,
I'm going to be working on that
project for a really long time
unfortunately.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Is this
like a 10-year problem?
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
This is probably
more like a 40-year problem.
So we still definitely
have a lot of work to do.
There's still a lot
of cleanup happening.
But the truth is that at least
within the next three years,
people will actually be able to
see changes that are happening
along their waterfront.
And they'll also be able to
access from the technology
perspective, but also from
a physical perspective,
their waterfront and be
updated about what is going on,
but also participate in the
decisions that are being made
and drive their own future
of the space they inhabit.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Well,
I've been sitting here
with Jackie Omotalade.
She is the Jackie O
here at Google I/O.
She's also an environmental
justice tech maven.
Thank you so much for
committing your life
and being an advocate for
the people of Southeast San
Francisco and for improving all
of our lives with technology.
Thank you so much.
JACQUELYN OMOTALADE:
Thank you very much.